hi i'm annie leblanc and i'm jayden
bartels and we're here with buzzfeed to
take the bff test
let's do it
check off each of the details you're
absolutely sure
you know about your best friend at the
end you'll get a squad of 20. share your
score with your bff and whoever has the
highest score wins
their birthday november 1st drafts of
the year 2004
2004 december 5th she almost didn't know
that's kind of i always
get december and september confused as
monks their ascological sign
sagittarius scorpio their middle name
grace isabel
the name of their siblings your sister's
name is hayley um
what are my brother's names jake
jack no josh okay josh
the other one starts with the j right
josh is right for one of them yes the
other name so two j's
three j's in the family is what you're
implying give me him what does it start
with
no it starts with an r elevator i said
no and then immediately
so she doesn't know it what is it it's
ryan
what the names of their parents yvonne
and sam katie and billy they're
celebrity crush
zendaya matthew gregor luber bloopers
their first job what we're literally
visiting
what do you want from us i mean this is
a job we'll say this
their favorite snack we both cheetos
the last show they binge watched it's
either euphoria or the good place
pick one you just said you were
re-watching the good place so that
great um and yours would be criminal
minds or or or that one
dexter yeah yes the name of their
all-time favorite nickelodeon show
victorious no i mean what else would it
be ninja turtles maybe maybe i like
ninja turtles
might have a problem with that do you
have i do yeah i've said it before and
you've made fun of me
sounds about right let me think she
needs to think it has to be funny if i
made fun of you for it can i have
multiple choice
no what does it start with no it's
spongebob
i made fun of you for that yeah you're
like spongebob that's so big [ __ ]
their favorite class in school for you
english for you and yours would be
science yeah
first time you met one two three bowling
they're hidden talent
and then nothing's hidden so yeah i
don't really know oh she can solve a
rubik's cube oh you can do
it oh yeah i can't play the ukulele
behind my head that's what she meant by
their favorite book i don't think we've
ever talked about books yeah i don't we
don't read
really um it's the scripts to sign up
they're dressing room must-haves would
be a hat
what like just things you want in your
dressing room oh dressing room as in
trailer
yeah for you it's a blanket snacks
here's a glitter
same but also like makeup yep deodorant
we both always are scared that we like
smell
their favorite band or singer the rex oh
scissor yes
their morning ritual you wash your face
oh i do so much in the morning yeah
there's so much
we do the same thing yeah we do the same
thing wash your face do us some makeup
pick a fit face on each other ask if the
fit is good
and then we're off to work and we're off
their favorite scene you shot together i
feel like we both have this we both have
this
one it's probably the trash compactor
exactly that's exactly what i was going
to say
we filmed a scene in a trash compactor
we did fall out of it once
yeah oh do you see that no i don't want
to show it but i got a breeze she's got
a bruise
the fans will love that one their coffee
order
yours is an iced caramel latte your last
time sort of thing that
tastes like nuts every time what is my
order you should know this i get coffee
all the time
i would get a nice caramel latte and
you'd get an iced vanilla latte
with almond milk correct that's it
that's it yeah oh i thought it was
way more no their go-to karaoke song
for both of us rather be that is such a
good song what is the song that i always
like i always play it
oh i can't see yeah you should can't say
it you can do that oh forget you okay
forget you yeah
18 out of 20. and both of the ones
we didn't get were because of her you
know a lot about your best friend
you have been friends for a while now
and you know all the basics and then
some
i can't wait to become even closer as
the years go on i agree
i agree i agree thank you thank you
buzzfeed it was a pleasure
i think that because this this quiz we
now know that we're bsi so wait what are
your brother's names
josh okay and ryan yes i don't think
that's true
no she's probably right
[Music]
you